Chelsea Handler is getting candid about
her past I feel like an adult in a new
essay for Playboy the Netflix host opens
up about the to abortion she had when
she was just at sixteen quote I happened
to [ __ ] up twice
Chelsea writes that she is quote
grateful that I came to my senses and
was able to get an abortion legally
without risking my health or bankrupting
myself or my family the essay comes just
as the Supreme Court struck down strict
abortion laws in Texas the 41 year old
comedian added quote I don't ever look
back and think of God I wish I'd had
that baby
strangely Chelsea's possible child came
up on a recent episode of her talk show
when Megan Fox stopped by there is a
soul that's around you and around your
dog that was a child that was conceived
at some point you should never feel like
you've dug or you made a bad choice
because that karma will always be
settled in the future either in this
lifetime or the next lifetime I didn't
feel like that ever until you came on
here at Hershey that my baby is running
around watching me with my dog